une ambiance tendue on l'a vu dans le
reportage quand même c'est une ambiance
tendue mais ça a été surtout la dernière
semaine mais c'était et quand elle est
intéressante et puis un territoire
intéressant surtout par un territoire je
l'ai lu d'un Condor bien sûr vous vous
étiez vous étiez sortant et vous étiez
un élu rural et en fait le redécoupage a
fait que vous vous êtes retrouvé sur un
canton qui est mixte finalement entre
zone rurale et aux oignons je suis un
canton mimi
voilà
le milieu urbain mais ça ne gêne pas
difficile à garder ou apprendre pour
pour la gauche on sait que la grande
partie des électeurs se trouve à talent
qui est détenu par le maire qui était
lui-même candidat qu'est-ce qui a fait
la différence en fait sur ce canton
c'est parce que vous vous incarnez
vraiment les deux zones
de droite au premier tour alors il y a
les deux
de liste nous on a su se réunir avant
comme le disait à mon ami Alain donc on
a fait on a travaillé en amont des
discussions on a choisi les meilleures
candidats le meilleur binôme avec
Christine Rodin Jacques et moi-même donc
on a fait une grosse campagne quand pas
comme je sais comme j'ai toujours fait
de villages en village d'immeubles en
immeuble et puis
les gens ont élu des gens et des élus
proximité on a beaucoup dit mais surtout
qui peuvent toucher comme je dis
toujours qui peuvent rencontrer qui
rencontrent tout le temps toute l'année
voilà est-ce que vous l'avez entendu
vous ce que Nicolas Sora qu'on a vu dans
le reportage vous l'avez pas entendu
dans la tranche précédente mais qui
disait la désespérance des gens
rencontrés dans des situations
difficiles et qui disait la sanction
aussi du gouvernement en disant mais il
faut avoir des résultats Dardar c'est
son expression ce sera peut-être le
l'expression de la soirée vous l'avez
rencontré ça vous tarder c'est une bonne
émission culturelle mais je pense pas si
je l'ai entendu bien sûr qu'on entend il
faut être sourd ou pas l'entendre mais
j'ai pas entendu que ça j'ai entendu
aussi
soyons heureux en Condor soyons heureux
ensemble et c'est une élections qui a
été politisée mais pas tellement dans le
secteur dans lequel je suis
et je suis lu quand même depuis deux
fois c'est la troisième fois que je suis
élu secteur que je connais bien donc la
politique moi je l'ai mise de côté
pour travailler sur ce territoire
l'ensemble du territoire de talents
tavenche et de son Berlin